airplane seats today are a lot smaller
than they used to be but size isn't the
only thing that makes a chair
comfortable they're just seats they
don't have the like Dynamic properties
of an ergonomic seat so we asked a
professional my name is Carla Jaspers
how she'd redesigned the airplane seat
to make it more ergonomically perfect
for starters I think there's definitely
an opportunity for a bit of subtle
adjustability specifically with the
lumbar support good lumbar support could
look like subtle yet movable lumbar
support that could be tailored to the
user's needs look at how flat the seat
back of this plane chair is now compare
that with this ergonomic office chair
the more points of contact your back can
have with a contoured and supportive
seat back the better spine is sort of
this natural s shape a very like subtle
s-shaped curve you have the cervical
thoracic and Lumbar curvatures of the
spine the lumbar support should hit you
right in the small of your back which is
why adjustability helps when catering to
various sitters I would also advocate
for something comparable around the head
and neck region adjusting up and down
that's a start I would say ideal state
it would be great if there was something
that was just a bit more contoured to
support the head if you think about a
child's car seat for example there's a
contoured head and neck support to not
only provide that comfort in different
positions but also as a safety Factor
then there's the seat pan if the seat
pan could be adjustable that would
accommodate people with varied leg
lengths at very least you could
re-examine sizing of the seats some
planes have decreased seat width from 18
inches to 17 to fit in more passengers
and in some cases seats can be as narrow
as 16 inches compare that with this
ergonomic desk chair with seat widths
ranging from 19 to 21.6 inches with
regards to seat width I think 18 to 19
feels more comfortable for most people
if passengers could adjust the depth of
their seat pan it would help them
support their knees and be able to sit
fully against the seat back so if you
have somebody with longer legs they
would get that much more leg and
postural support and for the person who
found the seat pan to be too deep if
they could bring the depth back it could
mitigate contact pressure sure or
discomfort for them as well the depth is
important in terms of supporting not
only the lower extremities but also the
spine if the seat pan is too deep or
compresses the back of the knees or the
legs it's great to have some sort of
support under the feet typical ergonomic
chairs allow their heights to be
adjusted so your feet can sit firmly on
the ground on an airplane a foldout foot
rest solves this problem a metal bar or
just some sort of component under there
that allows people to sort of anchor
their feet in for postural support which
like allows them to then shift back into
their seat premium seats can come with
those foot rests but economy seats
typically don't they're especially
important for shorter passengers to
support themselves properly but for
somebody like me I don't necessarily
want that so it would be nice if it went
away depending on the user this brings
us to the biggest hurdle leg room is
Paramount I think that's like really one
of the main needs for redesign on
airplanes the obvious way to add leg
room is moving seat rows farther apart
in increasing the seat pitch the average
seat pitch between airplane seats has
decreased from around 34 to 36 inches to
32 over the past few decades advocacy
group Flyers rights says that in some
planes it's down to 28 inches when you
start to shave inches off that distance
it compromises leg room and this is when
you run into issues with people's legs
being unable to fit when they're sitting
in their seats I think anything less
than 32 people start to notice
significantly that seat is too small
over 32 people find it to be more
spacious with regards to the materials
that are used Tempur-Pedic Foams or
memory foams come to mind something that
would keep its shape and really offer
that contour and support because these
armrests are predominantly hard plastics
or metal materials there's definitely an
opportunity to introduce some softer
materials to mitigate contact pressure
airplane seats have gotten significantly
more lightweight in recent decades and
Industry experts say it's difficult to
simultaneously optimized for durability
cost and comfort but for ergonomics
cushioning is key it's been successful
to think about foam or leather on other
types of seating it would just have to
be a material that could endure high
volume abuse on a scale of one to ten
economy Airline seats would probably
fall around a three or four with regards
to being ergonomically designed Jasper's
recommendations are based solely on her
expertise in ergonomics not necessarily
engineering safety cost and Longevity
it's a very technical area of design
there's obviously the constraints of
weight it's a very engineering heavy
design challenge for sure the
opportunity for design really stems from
not only giving a little bit more space
back to the passenger but perhaps also
adding a bit more support to the
components of the seat to provide
support for a range of fashion measures
being a woman who is six feet tall my
knees are always up against the seat in
front of me the seats are narrow on my
shoulders and hips the headrest it
either sort of pushes my head forward or
just sort of misses the mark altogether
I find myself sort of trying to collapse
into the seat and not disrupt my seat
mates but at the expense of my ability
to move or be comfortable it's kind of
become this um understood
experience where if you're flying
economy you have
sort of made peace with the idea that
it's probably not going to be a very
comfortable experience and are we okay
with that